if you like longwear lipsticks make sure
you look out for this kind of lipstick
these have the same Tech as longwear
liquid lipsticks but they're in Stick
form so it's easier to apply the way
these longwear lipsticks work is with a
volatile solvent like ISO do Deane
volatile means it evaporates easily when
it evaporates it leaves a long-lasting
silicone based film on your lips for a
while it was hard to make this in a
stick form and a big part of this was
just the packaging normal windup
lipstick packaging isn't airtight so the
volatile solvent would have just leaked
out you can see the packaging looks
pretty unusual and it's seal super tight
I find these a lot easier to apply than
liquid lipsticks but they're still a bit
drying on my lips hopefully they work
out a way around that soon